We've dealt with a lot of
that stuff on that passively I appreciate
it, yeah thank you so much for the call.
Let's go next caller from the 66 area go.
It's a wild day. Who's calling today from
626?
Good morning, David this is Steven, for Pasadena,
California.
He had... You were taking my call.
My pleasure, and I'm gonna join as a member
today 'cause I just love your show, and you
inspire
03/13/20 Page 8 of 18
davidpakmanshow­2020­03­13­commercialfree
me in erode.
Alright, so I don't know if I can get two
questions in. One will be fairly short, but
we'll see as my
first question first. Alright, so, as you
know, it's a safety measure. I was schedule
to go to Vegas this
weekend. MGM is temporarily closing their
Las Vegas pushes in Wake the worldwide plainchant.
Is that in a year that we in here, I E­schedule
to go to Vegas in April, place, a go for a
conference
and I've been talking to a to... We just don't
know what's going to happen, we don't know
if it'll hit
Vegas in a more serious manner.
Yeah, so right now and GM's closing on their
five properties there, their major properties,
they are
including ARA and others, they're closing
the buffets, every week they're gonna re­evaluate.
Okay, so my question is... And so I was going
to see my family at least each other all the
time. So
we're just gonna postpone till things hopefully
settle down. But my question is, do you think
that's
an over­to measure, or do you think it makes
sense and that you see maybe other food
establishments following suit?
Listen, here's the thing, I am not qualified
to comment on that and I don't wanna do so.
Unlike
Trump, who says doctors are shocked by how
much he knows about medical non­expert on
this, I
am going to go by what emergency managers
doctors, etcetera. Say, Here's what I can
tell you
though, Steve, if this all works it. Les closed
Harvard, all these universities doing classes
online
South by Southwest all this stuff. It might
feel like when you look at the number of cases
in the US
they claim it's about 1100. it's probably
more like 6000. if we were testing broadly
or whatever.
Imagine that this works. an inflection point,
infections and Transmission goes down. You're
gonna
have Monday morning quarter backers quarterback
saying This was too much, it didn't make any
sense. And they will be like the anti­vaccine
people, who say, measles is so rare. Why do
we need a
vaccine? Well, it's rare because we've had
a vaccine for decades much the same way as
I think is
this too much. Is it not, I don't know, but
we've gotta get it under control. I have things
I wanna be
doing, I have immuno­compromised people in
my family that I don't wanna expose, to this,
so is it
too much or not I don't know, but I'm gonna
go by what the public health officials say.
Okay, does it make you nuts when he can win
Trump compares it to the Flu as a... Yeah,
I mean,
that peace, that ignorance, I listen to comparing
it to Trump doesn't know anything about this.
It is
true that the death rate of 34 is likely significantly
overstating the death rate and that's good
news.
Trump said the death rate is probably lower.
He probably just got lucky. It's not like
he had any special insight. It seems that
that's true. South
Korea's death rate is 07. the US death rate
is 03, that's great, it is not like the flue
in almost any
other way.
So the comparison is not super relevant to
me, right? The Croatia, goes into the lungs
almost
immediately and creates what's known as ARDS
which is a C­Respiratory Distress Syndrome,
and
they have to treat that immediately. My dad
died of it many, many years ago, and that
we ended up
finding the lawsuit because they even said
yes as soon as suspected you gotta treat this
instead.
They waited 10 days and that was way too long
anyway. traject.
03/13/20 Page 9 of 18
davidpakmanshow­2020­03­13­commercialfree
Okay, any one other really quick question,
I think, who would you like to see Gobi and
pickers, are
running. You have any choices? I personally
like Stacy Abrams I think the odds of him
picking
Stacy Abrams are extremely, extremely low,
but a I sort of joke he should pick Barack
Obama to be
his running mate and I believe that...
Oh, I know a lot of people say legally, it
wouldn't work. I believe legally, it would
work. It's not
actually a bonus fight adjusting.
I'm not sure yet. I'm thinking about VP. And
we will see, we still have some time for that.
Steve
from Pasadena. Thank you so much for the call,
I appreciate it.